20 years later Bill Clinton and the
Democratic Party refused to learn the
lessons of the past even when confronted
with reality they have a problem
processing the truth during an interview
to push his new thriller that he
supposedly co-wrote with James Patterson
former President Bill Clinton was asked
this by NBC anchor Craig Melvin if you
were president now in 2018 with with
everything that's that's going on with
the me2 movement how would you have
approached the accusations differently
well I don't think it would be an issue
because people would be using the facts
instead of the imagined facts if the
facts are the same today I wouldn't a
lot of the facts have been conveniently
omitted to make the story work which
facts are those oh maybe this fact I did
not have sexual relations with that
woman well actually he did he had an
affair with that woman a White House
intern and then perjured himself in a
deposition now this all came to light in
a sexual harassment case brought against
Clinton by Paula Jones
was a utterly false statement
it depends upon what the meaning of the
word is is it's still ridiculous that he
said that yes it is oh my gosh every
time I hear that it's like I can't I
still can't believe he said that now the
president eventually admitted to the
relationship with the Winsky and called
it wrong and in a recent Vanity Fair
piece Monica Lewinsky herself wrote the
following it constituted a gross abuse
of power he was my boss he was the most
powerful man on the planet he was 27
years my senior with enough life
experience to know better
he was at the time at the pinnacle of
his career while I was in my first job
out of college when Clinton was
confronted with all of this he got very
very defensive I asked if you'd ever
apologize and you said you had I have
you've apologized her I apologized to
everybody in the world you didn't
apologize to her I have not talked to
her do you feel I thought of her in
Apollo I do III I dunno I never talked
to her
but I did say publicly on more than one
occasion that I was sorry that's very
different
well Melvin continued to press the
president former president about a
private apology causing his co-author
James Patterson to rush in like Alex
Cross Nate this thing has been it's 20
years ago come on let's talk about JFK
let's talk about you know LBJ stop
already stop already
that's the name of one of his new books
some of Harvey Weinstein's crimes took
place 20 years ago did they not and
should we just forgive and forget all of
those egregious assaults against women
as well Bill Clinton red-faced and
indignant refused to give an inch
I don't think Frederick you think
President Kennedy should have resigned
do you believe President Johnson should
resign I've tried to do a good job since
then with my life and with my work
that's all I have to say to you
I loved how he tried to turn the tables
on the reporter but bill he's the
reporter
he doesn't have to answer the question
to reconcile with his public past you do
even Clinton's own party at this point
seem just wanted to go away okay this is
the ruined past of the party confronting
it's pathetic present because like
Clinton the Democrats refused to learn
the lessons of the past
despite their previous embrace of sexual
predators from Weinstein to Spacey
the Democrats have erected a me-too
movement and created a political
infrastructure that they hope they hope
will deliver female voters to the polls
in November but Bill Clinton remains a
bothersome obstacle to their assuming
the moral high ground on sexual
harassment a CNN poll of registered
voters in May found that 80% of Democrat
voters considered sexual harassment a
top issue for them all only 30 percent
thirty eight percent of Republicans feel
the same way the Democrats believe that
this is their new wedge issue Obama and
Hillary Clinton come on let's remember
they were all about dividing Americans
using race and gender to drive people to
the polls amazingly Democrats have
embraced that approach today and while
Obama disparage working-class Americans
as bitter people clinging to their guns
and religion
Hillary questioned women's sanity for
daring to vote for Trump but the curious
thing beyond the impeachment and his
shameful behavior is that Bill Clinton
could actually teach the Democrats a lot
though of course he was a committed
globalist on issues like China getting
into WTO and NAFTA he was also a
southern Democrat and he did understand
that blue-collar Sensibility the working
people and remember when Clinton
declared this in his reelection year
State of the Union we know and we have
worked to give the American people a
smaller less bureaucratic government in
Washington and we have to give the
American people one that lives within
its means the era of big government is
over Clinton oversaw welfare reform
he collaborated with Republicans to pass
a balanced budget and he's signed that
Defense of Marriage Act a lot of people
forget that so this was after the 94
shellacking the Democrats had in that
midterm election cycle Clinton's like
well I got to work with the Republicans
now that made sense and even during his
wife's campaign he reportedly confronted
her staff about their seeming
disinterest in working class Americans
and he reportedly urged them to reach
out to those voters who were feeling
ignored his advice was dismissed though
led by Robby Mook Hillary's campaign
decided to double down on targeting
young Latino and black voters and their
effort to win the presidency well that
worked out well like Bill Clinton's
failure to read the signs of the times
and appreciate the lessons of the past
Democrats refused to acknowledge and
respect the voters that Trump has
brought into the fold should this
continue Clinton and James Patterson may
want to reconsider like a new title
maybe for their book when it premieres
in paperback the Democratic president is
missing and so are his voters and that's
the angle